still no incredible two cars has a
trilogy cars three so cars 3 is the
third Cars movie no one is really asking
for after cars two cars three stars the
character Lightning McQueen and not the
tow truck Larry the Cable Guy character
that is an improvement over - yes I
should illustrate for people who don't
know yet I was going to pass this right
out of cars world is a world where cars
are all alive I there are no drivers in
them in fact you never see human beings
in cars at all the machines have taken
over cars now run the world Lightning
McQueen is a race car he's on the top of
his game then the new way the young cars
comes out and he gets beaten he's in a
slump now he needs to train to be fast
again so he can find his mojo it's one
of the plots in cars three if I told you
that's all they had crammed in this
movie I'd be lying that's one of the
problems about cars three there's so
much packed into this movie so much they
want to do maybe shave off one or two
with the plot points you can focus up
some of the characters focus up the
movie focus up the story focus up the
plot I really believe there is a good
movie somewhere hidden deep in this mess
called cars through the second half of
this movie I like a lot more than the
first half the first half was like why
the jokes weren't landing actually for a
large portion of this movie I actually
stepped back of like a funny thing is
this movie's not actually cracking jokes
and I find that interesting then I
realize it's trying they're just not
landing which makes it so much worse
this is one dialogue scene between
Lightning McQueen and his personal
trainer and I was like that's actually
it's a prising Lee good dialogue moment
in this movie and then later on down the
line it tries to continue what they
started there and at the point they do
is just too late this movie's pretty
much the plot of three Rocky movies
crammed into one that's what I mean when
I say there's just a lot in here that
they need to shave off if you want to
take the plot of one of the Rocky movies
fine if you want people to walk out of
the movie be like oh it was like Rocky
this and Rocky's at mixed into one
that's all so far three too much too
much for a Pixar kids movie anyway
a blemish say this movie would be fun
for kids because you know you show
anything but even the kids in the
audience we're talking they're just
jabbering on about nothing when you have
kids in a kid's movie talking about
nonsense when they're not talking about
the movie
and I have to assume the movies boring
them - I didn't it really sounds like
I'm tearing this movie apart I didn't
hate it like I said the second half of
this movie maybe the last third of this
movie was actually good enough for me to
be like I feel like the movie was
directed by someone and that someone got
fired then they had another director
come in two completely different movies
that have been crammed into one maybe
they were planning on a car three and a
car as far than reflect that's never
going to happen
here's cars three in the end I walked
out of the movie just tired I was
yawning oh yeah okay and I was saying
probably not going to remember cars
three and t-minus one day yeah already
forgot all right guys so the car is
movies have you seen any of them what do
you think about them I personally
haven't been a fan but what about you
are you like yeah I don't get why they
keep making them are you like I don't
get the problem I enjoy whatever your
thoughts whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]